[Música]
a
k
[Música]
mais um mais um mais um mais um bora
bora B
Bora 10 segundos para fechar útimo agora
útimo
vem ixxo e mais um desse mais um desses
vai vai vai útimo
IX
boa Ô mas é
claro chambra chambra cud
cud
Valeu treinar F para você mostrar né
diante as
câmeras
Mas acabou agora valeu
turma demais mais um pr conta
hein ti foto aí ti foto aí nego
lindo esse
[Música]
carro
perf It's exactly the same this
side
[Risadas]
falou M cabir falei quem der não consigo
pagar o
dele
meia hora já tá aqui na tecnologia
né teologia fod Tu é doido Inteligência
Artificial pega qualquer foto que tem o
meu rosto e já joga diretamente nesse
nesse documento que ele
tá
esqueça que é que tu espera dessa
Lu espera um
knockout dentro dos dois primeiros
rounds um noout acho que de um noc Será
que vai ser mais uma luta que nós vamos
se surpreender não de perder eu digo mas
de tipo assim Ah tá não tá eu acho que
vai ser uma surpresa positiva mano
surpresa positiva no caso né Eu acho que
você tá o dois bom uma luta boa talvez
nunca nunca esteve treinando tão pesado
mas não no sentido ruim no sentido bom
tá ligado a gente vai ser uma diferença
de força do teu lado muito grande assim
também penso os caras vão ficar em
choque eu acho que você não você vai
ganhar velocidade Olha aí
Hype ai Ficou
massa essa roupa aí ficou massa
vermelhona ficou mano tu tinha que
entrar com aquela pela estrada Flora eu
vou
emho eu vou botar legenda assim ó vou
botar a legenda assim ó pai me conta
sobre aquela época que o senhor lot
box e eu mostro as fotos
no teu
perf Caral o
cabelo Peg 0
mod sou
contemporâ
[Aplausos]
[Música]
atemporal
[Aplausos]
[Música]
F
mais
[Música]
a
Meo sentio bem sentindo fazend a mesma
coisa
mesmo em outro outra vi de Treinamento
tambm outra de conexão com os meus minha
meuso
que decidido lá saber o que fazer assim
assado A mais B dessa
forma você goste muito dessa luta bom a
gente treinou muito para fazer um uma
luta bacana eu sou um artista eu gosto
de entretenimento Então eu quero que
seja uma uma coisa que te deixa feliz de
assistir n não como da última vez que
deixou muita gente aflita recebi muita
mensagem pessoas ficaram aflita mas tudo
bem é isso aí e eu espero que você curta
você cista Nate Espero que você vingue e
muito obrigado pela oportunidade aí de
gente fazer essa luta
bacana e curtir essa noite né vamos
vamos levar essa noite bacana
n